الارض تتشقق وامريكا تترنح بيضا يامر لابد
ان يخسر اردوغان ويدفع الثمن وبوتين يدير
الطاوله بمهاره ويقول ضاحكا افيقوا ايها
الامريكان لقد انتهى عسركم واصبحت اوامركم
بلا قيمه اردوغان يصفع بصفقه سلاح روسيه
ويقولها ان لم تبيعوا لنا الاف 35 سنشتري
السلاح الذي يسقطها لتشتعل الحرب البارده
بين حفيد ارطغرل والامريكان وبعيدا عن هذا
كله لماذا حاولت واشنطن اسقاط اردوغان في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه بينما ساندته موسكو
وسحقت اوامر امريكا وما هي ورقه الابتزاز
الامريكي التي احرقها اردوغان وجعلها
تذكره عبوره الى فتره رئاسته الثالثه وما
هو سر التقارب بين بوتين واردوغان وكيف
ساعد بوتين اردوغان في الانتخابات التركيه
دون ان يترك اثرا كما عملها سابقا
اللعب على المكشوف
يبدو ان الغوله الامريكي قد فقد اعصابه
واصبح اكثر جنونا فصفعت الدب الروسي
والتنين الصيني لا تتوقف واخر اصدائها هذه
الكفوف هو تجرد واشنطن من احد اهم حلفائها
فحالفوا واشنطن بالامس هو عدوها اليوم نعم
رجب طيب اردوغان هو الضربه التي افقدت
امريكا صوابها وجعلت بيضا يسرح علنا قبل
انتخابات الرئاسه التركيه باشهر قليله
بانه سيسقط اردوغان في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه قائلا اعتقد باننا يجب ان نتبع
نهجا مختلفا الان تجاه اردوغان يجب ان
ندعم قياده المعارضه عليه ان يدفع ثمن ما
اذا كان سنواصل بيع اسلحه معينه له ام لا
نعم فيمكننا دعم تلك العناصر من القياده
التركيه والاستفاده منها بشكل اكبر
وتشجيعهم زمام الامور وهزيمه اردوغان فهل
هي وقاحه سياسيه ام ان العداوه بين امريكا
واردوغان قد وصلت ذروتها لياتي الرد سريعا
من اردوغان قائلا اولئك الذين فشلوا
بالانقلاب في تركيا ويقومون الان بدعم
المعارضه اصبحوا لا يخجلون من قول ذلك
امام الكاميرات هؤلاء لا يعرفون سوى لغه
الانقلابات ويسعون لاحداث الفوضى
المجتمعيه بكل السبل مرت الايام سريعا
وبدات الحرب البارده ونقصد الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه واشنطن تدعم المنافسه
كمال كليك دار اوغلو بكل قوه وتساوي
اردوغان من خلف الستار اذا اردت الفوز في
الانتخابات فعليك التخلي عن اللاجئين
السوريين واجبارهم على العوده الى بلادهم
ولا تنسى ان تترك اليد الروسيه اردوغان
يرفض ويتحدى اوامر واشنطن قائلا لابد ان
نلقن امريكا درسا في الانتخابات بالذات
وبايض يرد عندما تامر امريكا فعلى الجميع
ان يطيع
اذا فزت فسافرض عقوباتا اقتصاديه على
روسيا يا الهي ماذا يحدث تحول الامر الى
معركه تكسير عظام واللعب اصبح على المكشوف
وذهبت هيبه امريكا
ورغم اوامر بايدن الصريحه باساحه اردوغان
عن الرئاسه التركيه جاءت نتيجه الانتخابات
لتقول لامريكا اوامرك اصبحت منتهيه
الصلاحيه وكلمتك ستنزل الارض فاذا اردوغان
ووقف في سياره مكشوفه امام شعبه يهنئونه
بالفوز ويهنئهم بالانتصار على امبرياليه
امريكا والغرب ورغم ان المعركه كانت تركيه
امريكيه كان الدب الروسي هو الغائب الحاضر
فقد تردد اسم روسيا مرات عديده وكانها
العملاق الذي وقف خلف اردوغان وسانده
معركته حتى ان حلف امريكا كيليغ دار اوغلو
قد اتهم روسيا بالتاثير على سير
الانتخابات قائلا ان لديه دلائل على ان
روسيا تقف وراء تسريبات مزيفه تخص المرشح
الرئاسي محرم
من الانتخابات ليرد الكرملين سريعا نعلن
رسميا انه ليس هناك شك بوجود اي تدخل واذا
زود احد ما السيد كليك دار اوغلو بهذه
المعلومات فانه كاذب ولكن مهلا هل كان
بوتين بعيدا حقا عن سير الانتخابات
التركيه
مخالب الدب الروسي تنهش الجسد الامريكي
يبدو ان اسم بوتين سيتحول الى كابوس
يطارده الامريكان والغرب في احلامهم فبرغم
عدم وجود اي دليل قاطع على تدخل روسيا في
انتخابات الرئاسه التركيه الا ان مخالب
بوتين كانت هي السلاح الذي شرح به اردوغان
وجه امريكا وضمت به موسكو اهم حلفاء
واشنطن والحليف الاقوى في حلف الناتو الى
صفها وكان بوتين يقول لاردوغان بالحضن
فيال السخريه السياسيه وكما يقولها
المصريون المصالح ضد صالح فمنذ عامين
قالها اردوغان ان لم تمنحنا واشنطن طائره
الاب 35 سنشتري ما يسقطها من روسيا نعم
امريكا لم تستجب واعطتهم وعودا اهون من
بيت العنكبوت رصيد الاتراك من الصبر نفد
ليهرول حفيد عثمان ويشتري منظومه اس 400
الروسيه ما يعني سلاح روسي داخل كبد حلف
الناتو اي انها كارثه بكل المقاييس استشاط
غضب واشنطن وهدد الترك باستبعادها من
برنامج المقاتله اف 35 التي وعدت بها
واشنطن ولم توفي بها لترد انقره بانها
تعتزم شراء دفعه من الصواريخ الروسيه بل
وربما يصل الامر الى شراء طائرات مقاتله
والسلاح متنوع من روسيا وعليها طائره 57
ولم يقف دعم موسكو لاردوغان عند هذا الحد
بل تكلل التعاون بينهما الى مشروع انشاء
محطه اوكويون والتي ستكون في تركيا وسيغذي
احشائها بالوقود الروسي واضف عليها مشاريع
الغاز الطبيعي الذي ستغرق به موسكو انقره
لتجعلها تتحكم في صنبور الغاز الذي يذهب
الى اوروبا ونقصد اتفاقيه انبوب البحر
الاسود والذي سيكون هو الوريد الرئيسي
لتزويد اوروبا بالغاز الام من ذلك هو ان
دوله كبرى بحلف الناتو تتسلح بسلاح روسي
ومدعومه بطاقه نوويه روسيه اي صفعه نزلت
على وجه كيا واشنطن كل هذا جعل من اردوغان
جدارا قويا لا يستطيع الغول الامريكي ان
يهزه او يزعزع ليظهر من خلف هذا الجدار
ذلك العثماني الذي يرشق سهاما اهانته على
مراى ومسامع العالم كله صوب واشنطن وكانت
اولى كلماته بعد الفوز سنعزز التعاون مع
روسيا وسنعمل على تنفيذ مشروع الغاز
الروسي الذي سيضمن لنا مكانه كبرى في
مجالات النقل والطاقه ربما كان من الممكن
اسقاط اردوغان بالبلطجه الامريكيه او
بسياسه القبعات السود ونقصد الاغتيالات
فماذا يحضر اردوغان من عتاد للايام
القادمه
النفاق السياسي
ادرك اردوغان ان الغطاء الامريكي لا يحمي
من البرد والمتغطي به عريان كما يقولها
العرب وبشان العرب فعداوتهم مع الدول
العربيه والبحر المتوسط عموما قد ترتد
عليه وتنقلب ضد مصلحته ومساراته السياسيه
ليبدا اردوغان بسياسه الفلتره السياسيه
نريد اتفاقات وتصالحات ولا نريد شوائب
وخلافات ليذهب بتلك الجهه ولي العهد
السعودي قائلا فلنترك خلافاتنا جانبا ولا
التفت للقادم ولم يكتفي بالصلاه في قبله
المسلمين لتدور الايام وياتي مونديال قطر
نعم كاس العالم هنا يجد اردوغان ضلته
ويلتقي بالرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي في
حراره ذلك السلام الساخن ليثير ذلك شهيه
الفراعنه والاتراك نحو السلام لتبدا بعده
الاجتماعات الدبلوماسيه مع مس اتراك وذلك
على مستوى رفيع فبعد معركه الصناديق
التركيه هنا اول رئيس عربي يهنئ اردوغان
بالفوز نعم الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي كان اول رئيس عربي يهنئ اردوغان
بالفوز وعلى ايه حال لا يمكن الاستهانه
بسياسه تصفيه الخلافات خصوصا لتركيا فهي
من ناحيه تضمن لاردوغان مكانا بين دول
البحر المتوسط ودول الخليج ومن ناحيه اخرى
تعزز من تعاونه مع بوتين لان اغلب تلك
الدول هم من اصدقاء موسكو الحميمين وهنا
السؤال هل كان ما يفعله اردوغان الان يضمن
له شعبيه كبيره بين العرب
حرق ورقه الابتزاز
رغم العداء الشديد بين اردوغان وامريكا
والغرب عموما لا يمكننا القول بان الزعيم
التركي ملاك قد هبط من السماء فهناك مواقف
عديده للزعيم التركي تدعو للتساؤل منها
تعامله مع قضيه اللاجئين السوريين فمنذ
الحرب السوريه كانت تركيا هي صاحبه اكبر
عدد من اللاجئين السوريين على مستوى
العالم باكثر من اربعه ملايين لاجئ وكان
اردوغان دائما الدفاع عن قضيتهم وعن
وجودهم على الاراضي التركيه ولكن تغير
موقفه في الانتخابات الاخيره ففي الوقت
الذي كان منافسه كليجدار اوغلو يعد الشعب
التركي بانه سيعمل على اجبار اللاجئين
السوريين على الخروج من تركيا كان اردوغان
لا يريد الحديث عن تلك القضيه ولكنه شعر
بانها اصبحت ورقه ضغط وابتزاز من منافسه
قد يكسب بها دعم الشعب التركي فتراجع عن
موقفه واعلن انه سيعمل على اعاده اللاجئين
السوريين الى بلادهم عبر قوانين معينه
وانه قد تمت اعاده اكثر من 450 الف لاجئ
بالفعل ليعلن لاحقا لالغاء ذلك القرار
قائلا نحن نبني بيوتا للسوريين بدعم من
قطر ولن نخرج اي سوري من تركيا بل معززا
ومكرما وليست قضيه اللاجئين هي فقط علامه
الاستفهام حول سياسه اردوغان بل ايضا اهم
قضيه تشغل كل العرب وهي قضيه فلسطين
والعلاقات مع اسرائيل ففي الوقت الذي كان
يعلن فيه اردوغان انه يحلم باعاده الخلافه
الاسلاميه كانت انقره تطبع العلاقات مع تل
ابيب على اوسع نطاق في ازمه كورونا وعندما
قلت التعاملات التجاريه بين كل الدول بشكل
ملحوظ زاد حجم التجاره بين تركيا واسرائيل
عن معدله الطبيعي وتجاوز عشره مليارات
دولار في عام واحد قد تقول ان مبلغ عشره
مليارات دولار ليست مبلغ عندما نتحدث عن
حجم التجاره بين الدول ولكن في حاله تركيا
واسرائيل الامر مختلف يا عزيزي فحجم
التجاره بين البلدين لم يصل الى هذا الرقم
من قبل ومعنى ذلك ان التعاون بينهما كان
في تزايد كل عام عما قبله والعام الذي وصل
فيه حجم التعامل التجاري بين تركيا
واسرائيل الى هذا الرقم كان هو الاسوا في
التجاره العالميه منذ بدايه القرن الواحد
والعشرين وفي الوقت نفسه كان وزير
الخارجيه التركي مولود شاوش اوغلو يعلن ان
بلاده تامل في استقبال اعداد كبيره من
السياح الاسرائيليين ما رايكم بسياسه
العثماني رجب طيب اردوغان وماذا سيقدم
لتركيا في الايام القادمه وكيف سيتعامل مع
ملف اللاجئين السوريين